foreign
aspect of Our Lives the dark and rebelly
of the digital realm is going closer
cyber threats and attacks are on the
rise targeting everything from personal
data to critical infrastructure in
response organizations are investing
heavily in fortifying their digital
defenses spurring a surge in demand for
cyber Security Professionals among these
experts are penetration testers or
ethical hackers who specialize in
identifying vulnerabilities before
malicious hackers can exploit them this
video delves into the fascinating realm
of penetration testers salaries
examining the factors that influence
their earnings and evolving trends that
shape the cyber security job market
so these are the topics that we will be
covering in this video
the role of a penetration testers
factors influencing penetrating salaries
Trends in penetration tester salaries
and salary over penetration test
now before moving forward and understand
the role of a penetration tester let me
ask you a quick question so what is the
primary goal of a penetration tester a
developing new software be finding
vulnerabilities in systems C providing
customer support or decreating marketing
strategy you can select the correct
option and write in the comment section
below you can pause this video and
answer in the comment section now let's
move forward and understand the role of
a penetration tester
so a penetration tester is like a
computer detective they pretend to be a
bad guys to find weak points in computer
stuff like systems networks and apps
this helps stop real bad guys from using
those weak points but the test is follow
strict rules and only do this with the
permission from the companies they help
their main job is to find problems early
so companies can fix them and be better
protect it from cyber attacks so this is
the role of a penetration tester next
let's understand the factors influencing
penetration tester salaries so several
factors contribute to
to the wide range of salaries seen in
the field of penetration testing first
would be experience
as with any profession X plays a pivotal
role in determining a penetration tester
salary
individuals entering the field and
limited experience might command a lower
salary compared to seasoned
professionals who have proven track
record of identifying critical
vulnerabilities next factor is skill set
the depth and breadth of penetration
tester skill set directly impact their
earning potential Proficiency in various
tools programming languages and
methodologies used in cyber security
assessments can lead to higher
compensation
third is certifications
industry recognized certifications carry
considerable weight in cyber security
field
for example postgraduate program in
cyber security by simply learn with the
help of this course you can become an
expert in the dynamic realm of cyber
security this course is designed to
empower you with essential skills and
this course ensures you're well prepared
to thrive in this rapidly evolving field
stay ahead of the curve by learning
about the latest cyber security Trends
and advancements elevate your career
prospects and secure your future with
the specialized program
enroll now to embark on a journey
towards becoming a sought after cyber
security professional all right now
coming to the next factor which is
geographical location the geographical
location in which a penetration tester
Works can signifially influence their
salary Tech hubs and cities with high
concentration of business tend to offer
higher salaries to attract and retain
top talent however the cost of living
also comes into play as higher salaries
in some areas might be offset by higher
living expenses at last we have is
specialization penetration testers can
specialize in various areas such as web
applications network security or mobile
devices
utilization can lead to higher salaries
as organizations seek experts with an
in-depth understanding of specific
vulnerabilities so these were the
factors that were influencing
penetration tester salaries now let's
move forward and understand the trends
in penetration tester salaries so the
dynamic nature of the cyber security
landscape is reflected in the salary
transfer penetration testers
so first would be rapid salary increases
the increasing frequency and servity of
cyber attacks have heightened the demand
for skill cyber Security Professionals
including penetration testers
this demand has led to a steady forward
trajectory in beneficial tester salaries
over the past decade the second is
remote work Revolution the covid-19
pandemic has catalyzed the acceptance of
remote work across various Industries
including cyber security
this shift has expanded the talent pool
allowing organizations to hide
penetration testers from different
Geographic locations consequently salary
negotiations might be influenced by
factors beyond traditional office
locations next is shortage of skilled
professionals
the shortage of skill penetration
testers remains a significant challenge
for organizations seeking to strengthen
their cyber security defenses the
scarcity of qualified candidates has
created a competitive job market
prompting companies to offer enticing
compensation packages to attract and
retain top talent so these were the
trends in penetration industry service
now let's come to the interesting part
which is salary for penetration industry
so according to various sources the
salary of a penetration tester can vary
depending on the location experience
skills and certification of the
individual here are some average salary
estimates for penetration testers in
India and us first India the average
salary for a penetration trusted in
India is 5 lakhs per annum the salary
range is from 4 lakhs to 20 lakhs per
hour the pay also depends on the skills
and certifications of the penetration
test the next is USU the average salary
for up and if you're interested in U.S
is 128 000 per year the salary range is
from 107 000 to 166 000 per n the pay
also depends on the location experience
skills and certifications of the
penetration test so as you can see
penetration testing is a rewarding
career option for those who are
interested in cyber security however it
also requires a lot of technical
knowledge creativity problem solving
skills and ethical standards if you are
considering becoming a penetration
tester then do check out our course the
link is mentioned in the description box
also listen to what our Learners has to
say about our course hi I'm Philip I'm
61 years old and last year I upskill
with simply learned postgraduate program
in cyber security after working 30 years
in the IIT sector in various different
profiles I'm happy to tell you that I
was able to clear and pass my cissp and
ccsp certification exams on the first
attempt after taking the course course I
must say was packed with practical
examples it was led by highly skilled
certified instructors I worked with many
companies before the security analysts
and the architect on a contract basis
but I needed some stability which I got
with the job I just started with Infosys
as a cyber security consultant happened
after I took the course first and
foremost I've been a learner be a
learner first
alright guys with that we have come to
the end of this video If you like this
video please give it a thumbs up I hope
it really helped you all thanks for
watching stay safe and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you